PETE LEPAGE: You've
found the perfect image
for your responsive site.
It looks great on
desktop but loses its awe
when viewed on a phone.
Between the change in
orientation and the smaller
screen, all of the fine detail
becomes impossible to see.
Displaying different images
based on device characteristics
is called art direction.
And the picture element was
designed exactly for this.
Inside is a list of source tags.
Each source tag includes a
set of rules and the image
to use when those rules are met.
You also need to
include an image tag.
The browser enumerates
the list of sources
and checks the rules.
As soon as it gets a match,
it'll use that image.
If no source tags are matched
or if picture isn't supported,
the browser uses the
image tag-- perfect
for backwards compatibility.
Let's take a look
at this in action.
The first source tag
specifies a media query
and checks if the browser
width is over 800 pixels.
If it is, the full
size image is used.
But if the first source
tag was not matched,
the next one is checked,
testing if the browser
width is greater
than 400 pixels.
If it is, the browser
will use that image.
When the browser width
is less than 400 pixels
or the picture element
isn't supported,
the browser uses the image
specified by the image tag.
Styling the picture
element is done
by applying CSS to the image
tag, not the picture element
itself.
This is also where you
should specify the alt
text and any other
attributes that are needed.
There you go.
You now know how
to use the picture
element for art direction.
The picture element is
only supported natively
in Chrome 38.
But other browser vendors have
committed to implementing it.
You can use it knowing that
you won't break older browsers
or grab Picture Fill, a library
for supporting older browsers.